I'm gonna run to the restroom guys talk
amongst yourself really got to go to the
bathroom right here talk [ __ ] about me
with a pillow
you're welcome to close the door
thank you English fairy no you see his
lips dude what about his lips
yeah I saw dried come on the tip on his
lip what a cheeky buggers taking bastard
no but he is he is like really weird huh
his eyes he's just a weird-looking white
it it's like did you just get hit by a
car right Renzo read the do grab me
around ow it's the ugliest white dude
I've ever seen it's like it's like
somebody drew him like a cartoon yeah
like a frickin white Franken white he's
great Nicky's been running that's the
show called Bobby Lee has nips write me
a great show
so what so when you were in England
those who you but you're you're you're
why are you a United fan and not a city
fan I just want to you because I've
always wondered how that happens how do
you choose if you're born in well
generally yeah yeah wherever you're born
that's that's like that the team that
you like all right from clithero our
football team sucks it's not even really
a real team and we ever stadium and what
I it's not a stadium we have a ground do
you play in the FA Cup do I play oh yeah
they do yeah every every football team
starts in the FA Cup whittle it down to
the finals but yeah they suck you know
they're like division 7000 nobody sir oh
yeah yeah I'm Manchester is close by and
in those days in the 80
is Manchester night was the team so that
was out you know a glory hunt or
whatever but I'm not the biggest
football fan a common claim to be I'd be
full of [ __ ] if I could sit here and say
that I'm the most I just want to say
enjoy it
that team yeah with Giggs right that's
right yeah
but Nikki but yeah Laguna Beckham was
there's a pulse Cole's
Cantina Cantona dude that team was
[ __ ] know back in the day they were
killing it but Arsenal was good back
then too yeah a lot of good teams yeah
now it's all about man Susie yeah that's
all I know so like if you get into a cab
in London a black cab first thing they
say cuz everybody's obsessed with
football anything sorry soccer yeah
first question what seem you support
mate and then you know you got a stuff
man United Oh [ __ ] you had a hard one
this week did you pal and they start
getting into an arai you know you see
the headlines so you know a little bit a
little bit of surface knowledge and then
they got deep into it okay stop right
there I'm sorry but we've exhausted my
knowledge okay I know who wanted the
weekend then I don't really give a [ __ ]
about anything else
but why don't you give a [ __ ] I was
never it's the same reason you don't
watch a basketball match enforce that's
right I like I like combat sports I was
always obsessed with martial arts yeah
start martial arts when I was eight
years old and which one Japanese jujitsu
yeah it's worth stems from right
it really does that's why all martial
arts them from from Japan yep really yes
the Chinese don't have anything to do
with it
they [ __ ] might do a lot of [ __ ]
Chinese martial art get over in the UFC
yeah young man it is [ __ ]
you know ya know that's a no-no so
Japanese jiu-jitsu yeah over 5,000 years
old and all them say Oh a lot of martial
art so part of me you're right we're
taking from that so for example judo
took the throws and accentuated them
made them better karate took the strike
it made it better
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu took the ground
element and made that so much better so
on and so forth no love for Taekwondo
say this though you [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright because you stole these [ __ ]
no no that's not it what is it I'm going
to tell you something right now please
is that Korea is I'm gonna say a half a
peninsula we're so small right and yet
we have some great stars in the UFC no
no you did I'm tryin zombies a beast
that guy what's his then that little the
super boy no you're right some great
guys yeah Korean Zombie just lost I know
he did but that was a great that was a
great yeah and you know Koreans you know
we're busy called gun stone yeah he's
bad right so I'm kind of proud of and he
was gone cuz he was in the military for
that was a Korean Zombie a how many
Filipinos are in the smashing machines
yes no no sorry directing a Filipino
what Brandon Vera now any fights for
live there too but how many boxers do we
have doesn't matter we're not talking
about boxing I'm just saying there's a
combat we've what are you doing with
your feet Manny ground you're dead
[Music]